"The Batman" is a complicated film with several
narrative threads unraveling at the same time.
Some of the story revelations go by so quickly,
they can leave audiences wondering about their
meaning.
Keep watching to see the most confusing moments
in "The Batman" explained.
Warning: spoilers ahead.
In interviews promoting the film, star Robert
Pattinson talked about how different Reeves'
vision for the source material was.
"I just knew there was something radically
different from anything we'd seen in Batman
movies before."
He felt that this new direction was something
viewers would find evident from the film's
shocking opening moments.
He wasn't wrong, either.
The movie opens with a POV shot someone of
peering through a window of a large home,
where a small child is playing with his father.
But it's initially unclear what we're looking
at.
It's a jarring but appropriate way for a film
like this to open.
It almost looks as if we're seeing is a young
Bruce Wayne before that fateful night that
his parents were killed, which dovetails nicely
with this child's grief mirroring Bruce's.
Instead, it's the Riddler stalking his prey,
Gotham's corrupt Mayor, before going in for
the kill.
The patience to let the scene linger for as
long as it does really sets up the tone and
pace of the film.
The first time we see mob boss Carmine Falcone,
it's through Selena's eyes as Bruce monitors
her infiltration of 44 Below.
However, the first time he and Bruce meet
face to face, it's at the mayor's funeral,
where Falcone remarks that Bruce is the only
person in the city more reclusive than he
is.
Falcone tells a brief story about how Thomas
Wayne once saved his life after the mobster
was shot.
He showed up on Wayne's doorstep, with Bruce's
father operating on Falcone on the dining
room table, while Bruce watched from afar.
"You don't think that means something?"
Falcone asks Bruce.
Bruce says it means his father took the Hippocratic
Oath.
When Falcone laughs at this, Bruce doesn't
understand what's so funny.
"Hippocratic" sounds to Falcone like "hypocrite."
Even though Bruce thinks his father was a
good man, Falcone remembers the day Thomas
Wayne asked him to handle a problem for him.
It resulted in a murder, so he finds it hilarious
that Bruce doesn't know the full scope of
his own father's complex morality.
The revelation that Falcone murdered Selina's
mother that is one of the film's more nuanced
reveals.
When Selina tells her tragic origin story
to Bruce, she mentions that after her mother
was murdered, Falcone let Selina get swallowed
up by Gotham's awful social services system.
It's not until Annika's message is discovered
on Selina's voicemail that we're able to put
the rest of the pieces together.
On the recording, we can hear that Falcone
is the rat they've been searching for and
that he's the one who personally killed Annika.
Even worse, he did it with his bare hands
around her neck.
Falcone's penchant for strangling the women
who get in his way is confirmed even further
when he tries to kill Selina, trying to choke
her, just like he did to her mother.
Once The Riddler has been caught, he is revealed
to be forensic accountant Edward Nashton,
a traumatized orphan who uncovered the rot
at the core of the Gotham Renewal Fund.
It was the corruption of the city that turned
him into a vengeful killer.
When rooting through his apartment for more
clues about his motivations, Batman sees that
he has one last password-protected video to
unlock.
Based on Nashton's news clippings, Bruce is
concerned that the Riddler has figured out
who The Batman really is.
"I think I'm his last target."
When Batman arrives at Arkham, Nashton tells
a long story about how he hated Bruce Wayne
while growing up in an orphanage.
To Nashton, it seemed that the only sympathy
Gotham had for lost children was given to
a billionaire kid who lived in a mansion.
It feels like Nashton is ramping up to reveal
the truth, but it becomes clear that he's
not taunting Bruce about knowing his true
identity.
Rather, the Riddler is lamenting the fact
that together, the two of them took down every
one of his targets except Wayne.
Nashton isn't talking to Batman as an adversary
but as a partner.
After all, they're both vengeful, angry men
who suffered in their youth and want to root
out corruption and see justice served.
This moment and its implications are the beginning
of the end for Bruce relying entirely on fear
and violence.
He sees the limits of what he has done, and
worse sees the evil his war on crime has inadvertently
inspired.
Another revelation takes place within Arkham's
walls before the final credits begin to roll.
As Nashton has a meltdown in his cell knowing
that Batman has thwarted his plans, a friendly
cell neighbor comforts him.
Through their interaction, it becomes pretty
clear that the individual Nashton is befriending
is supposed to be the Joker.
However, what's confusing is Barry Keoghan's
casting.
Fans assumed that he'd be playing the Joker
in some kind of post-credits scene.
This scene taking place before the film's
actual closing moments is a bit of a shock,
but largely because it begs the question of
how the Joker ended up in Arkham.
Is he already the Joker?
Did Batman catch him in a previous adventure?
Do we really need another live-action Joker
so soon after Joaquin Phoenix's Oscar-winning
turn with the character?
Only time will tell if he shows up in a potential
sequel.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.